From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole. Ira Glass is going to be back next week.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔。艾拉·格拉斯下周会回来。
So Ted Cruz dropped out of the race this week for president, and a lot of Republican voters were thrilled. But a lot of them were heartbroken and confused, asking themselves a lot of questions about themselves and their party and what they stand for. And I wanted to talk with my colleague Zoe Chace because she'd been doing a lot of campaign coverage for the show, talking to Cruz supporters.
泰德·克鲁兹本周退出了总统竞选，许多共和党选民感到兴奋，但也有很多人感到心碎和困惑，他们开始审视自己、党派以及他们的信仰。我想和我的同事佐伊·蔡斯聊聊，因为她一直在为节目进行竞选报道，采访了许多克鲁兹的支持者。
Hi, Sean.
你好，肖恩。
Hello.
你好。
Yeah, I was worried about the Cruz supporters, to be honest. Some people had been waiting for 30 years for somebody like Ted Cruz to get as far as he did-- this strong, Christian, very conservative evangelical candidate. And there was one guy I knew that might be pretty heartbroken, and I wanted to check in with him. I had to call Tony.
说实话，我当时很担心克鲁兹的支持者。有些人等了30年才等到像泰德·克鲁兹这样的人走得这么远——一位坚定的、基督教背景的、非常保守的福音派候选人。我认识一个人，知道他一定会非常难过，我想去看看他。我得给托尼打个电话。
And just say who Tony is again.
再介绍一下托尼是谁。
Tony Beam is a radio host in South Carolina. Conservative, evangelical Christian talk radio. Remember, we did a story on Tony a couple months ago. And the issue was that when his evangelical listeners started embracing Donald Trump, Tony felt betrayed and confused and upset.
托尼·比姆是南卡罗来纳州的一名电台主持人，主持保守派福音派基督教谈话节目。还记得我们几个月前做过关于托尼的报道吗？当时的问题是，当他的福音派听众开始支持唐纳德·特朗普时，托尼感到被背叛、困惑和苦恼。
So how is he taking the news?
那他现在对这个消息有什么反应？
He couldn't even bring himself to watch it on TV.
他甚至无法让自己在电视上看这个消息。
My wife told me. This is exactly what happened. I was sitting in the living room, playing the guitar, when my wife got home last night. And she put-- because I hadn't turned any of this stuff on. I knew what it was going to be. I couldn't take the Trump edition of Fox News. So I'm sitting there playing the guitar, and she came in and put her hand on my shoulder and said, "I'm really sorry. I just heard that Cruz dropped out."
是我妻子告诉我的。事情就是这样。昨晚我妻子回家时，我正坐在客厅弹吉他。她走进来——因为我一直没打开电视，我知道会看到什么，我实在无法忍受福克斯新闻的“特朗普版”。我正坐着弹吉他，她走过来把手搭在我的肩膀上说：“真的很抱歉，我刚听说克鲁兹退出了。”
What song were you playing?
你在弹什么歌？
I'm just learning. Believe it or not, I'm 58 years old, and I'm trying to learn to play the guitar. So I was playing a little Creedence Clearwater Revival because I'm a big John Fogerty fan. So I was playing "Have You Ever Seen the Rain?"
刚在学。信不信由你，我58岁了，正在试着学弹吉他。当时我在弹一点清水乐团的歌，因为我是约翰·福格蒂的铁杆粉丝。我在弹《你见过雨吗？》。
[MUSIC - "HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THE RAIN?"]
[音乐 - 《你见过雨吗？》]
It occurs to me, Zoe, that a lot of people who were upset about this, they can sort of just go hide or drink somewhere. And he has to be on the radio, upset.
佐伊，我想到一点，很多对此感到难过的人，他们可以躲起来或者去喝一杯。但他必须要在电台上表现出难过。
He has to go on the radio, live, at 7:00 in the morning with all his feelings.
他得在早上7点直播，带着所有的情绪面对听众。
"All right, good morning, everybody. The world keeps turning."
“好了，大家早上好。世界仍在转动。”
I cracked the microphone and I said, OK, it's a Trump kind of day. The Trumpists are trumpeting. And so here's my question to you listening to the show.
我打开麦克风说，好吧，今天是“特朗普日”。特朗普的支持者们正在大声疾呼。那么，我想问问正在听节目的各位一个问题。
"The question of the day is, are you going to vote for Hillary or one of her top donors?"
“今天的问题是，你是打算投票给希拉里，还是投票给她的主要捐赠者之一？”
He's talking about Donald Trump.
他在说唐纳德·特朗普。
"That's pretty much the choice that we're left with. We've got Hillary or a Hillary supporter. So there you go."
“这基本上就是我们剩下的选择了。我们要么选希拉里，要么选希拉里的支持者。情况就是这样。”
Tony is never going to get behind Donald Trump. He sees him as a fake conservative. He's just an opportunist.
托尼永远不会支持唐纳德·特朗普。在他眼里，特朗普是个虚伪的保守派，只是个投机分子。
He doesn't share his values.
他与托尼的价值观不同。
Right, he just grabs principles when he wants them and then just drops them when he doesn't anymore.
没错，他只是在需要的时候利用原则，不需要的时候就抛弃它们。
Right.
对。
Tony has built his entire life around Christian values, and he doesn't think that Trump has those. And now he's in this situation where he's looking ahead over the next couple months. He has a live radio show, two hours every single day. He's going to be dealing with this. So I asked him, Tony, what is the plan? How are you going to handle this on the radio?
托尼的一生都建立在基督教价值观之上，他不认为特朗普拥有这些。现在他陷入了这种境地，他还要展望未来几个月。他每天有两小时的现场广播节目，他不得不面对这一切。所以我问他：托尼，有什么计划？你在电台上打算怎么处理这件事？
I'm just going to talk about what's going on. It's going to be kind of like there's been a wreck. And I'm going to describe it. You know, the rescue efforts.
我就谈论正在发生的事情。这就像是发生了车祸。我会描述现场，你知道，描述救援工作。
Like you're reporting on a big natural disaster or something.
就像你在报道一场大型自然灾害一样。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的，是的。
What do you think your listeners want you to do? What are they looking for from you?
你觉得你的听众希望你怎么做？他们想从你这里得到什么？
Unity. Hold hands. Sing "Kumbaya." And to be fair, listen, I've been much more conservative than our nominee for the last three or four cycles.
团结一致。携手同行，共唱《团结一致》。说实话，在过去三四届选举中，我一直比我们的候选人更保守。
Yeah, Mitt Romney, John McCain.
对，米特·罗姆尼，约翰·麦凯恩。
Yeah, Romney, John McCain, Bob Dole. So I've always told people, look, the primary is where we make a decision as a party. And then we've got to come together and vote for the nominee.
是的，罗姆尼、麦凯恩、鲍勃·多尔。所以我总是告诉人们，看，初选是我们作为一个党派做出决定的过程，然后我们必须团结起来，投票给胜出的候选人。
And so now I've got people pounding on me. Well, you're a big hypocrite because your man lost, and now you won't unify. You won't get behind Trump.
所以现在有人在攻击我，说我是一个大伪君子，因为我支持的人输了，现在我不肯团结了。我不肯支持特朗普。
Well, to me it's a completely different scenario. I've never felt like I was voting for the lesser of two evils. I didn't think those guys were evil. I thought they were different from me. I wished they were more conservative.
但在我看来，这是完全不同的情况。我从没觉得自己在“两害相权取其轻”。我不觉得那些人是“坏”的。我认为他们只是和我不同。我希望他们更保守一些。
Right, they just weren't your top pick.
对，他们只是不是你的首选。
That wasn't my top pick. I mean, I can't vote for Donald Trump for president.
那不是我的首选。我是说，我无法投票给唐纳德·特朗普当总统。
So when you did the first story, there was this guy.
当你做第一个报道时，有个家伙。
Barry.
巴里。
Yes, Barry, who was like the Trump interpreter.
是的，巴里，他就像是特朗普的翻译官。
Yeah, he called Tony all the time to harass him about Donald Trump.
对，他总是打电话给托尼，骚扰他关于唐纳德·特朗普的事。
Yes. And did he call this time?
没错。那他这次有打电话吗？
Of course. He called the morning after Cruz had dropped out. Tony said, of course Barry called him and tried to sell him on Trump and party unity.
当然。克鲁兹退出后的第二天早上他就打了。托尼说，巴里当然找过他，试图说服他支持特朗普和党内团结。
Barry and I, look, we have a good relationship. And he was telling me-- he said, "man, there's room for you, brother. You can get on the Trump train with me." He said, it's not-- because I played the sound bite where Trump was talking about unity and we're going to love everybody.
我和巴里，听着，我们关系不错。他当时对我说：“伙计，兄弟，这里有你的位子。你可以跟我一起上特朗普号列车。”他说，这不是——因为我播放了特朗普谈论团结、我们要爱每一个人的音频。
"This country, which is very, very divided in so many different ways, is going to become one beautiful, loving country. And we're going to love each other. We're going to cherish each other. We're going to take care of each other. And we're going to have--"
“这个在许多方面都非常分裂的国家，将会变成一个美丽、充满爱的国家。我们要相亲相爱，要珍惜彼此，要互相关照。我们将会拥有——”
And then Barry said, "yeah, man, this is not the Trump Train. This is the Love Train. You've got to get on board."
然后巴里说：“是啊，伙计，这已经不是‘特朗普列车’了。这是‘爱之列车’。你得加入我们。”
"It's not the Trump Train anymore. It's the Love Train."
“这不再是特朗普列车了。这是爱之列车。”
"It's the what? Love Train?"
“这是什么？爱之列车？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Bob, you've got to find-- I've got Bob over here. Bob's got to find "The Love Train" by The O'Jays. So we'll pull that up in just a minute. We're going to have another Woodstock. I mean, it's going to be 1969 all over where there will be people singing, are you going to San Francisco? It's going to be a Republican love-in. Not."
“鲍勃，你得找到——我这边有鲍勃。鲍勃得找到O'Jays合唱团的《爱之列车》。我们一会儿就放这首歌。我们要举办另一场伍德斯托克音乐节。我是说，这会重现1969年，人们会唱歌，‘你要去旧金山吗？’这会是一场共和党的爱的大联欢。才怪。”
Tony remembers those first Republican debates when Trump was talking and saying all this outlandish stuff. And his listeners were calling in and being like, we love this guy, and this guy is speaking for me. And it just felt so viscerally wrong to him, like he was like, this is not who we are. This is not who we Republicans are. And then he wakes up one morning, and Cruz is out.
托尼还记得最初的共和党辩论，当时特朗普在说那些离谱的话。他的听众打电话进来，说他们喜欢这个家伙，他代表了他们的心声。这让托尼感到本质上的不对劲，他觉得：这不是我们。这不是我们共和党人。然后一天早上醒来，克鲁兹出局了。
Today I have to face the fact that maybe that is who we are. I mean, you realize 6-- what was it? You've probably seen the numbers. 6 or 7 out of 10 Republicans-- I think it's been consistently 6 out of 10 agree that we ought to ban all Muslims from coming to the United States. And so maybe this whole thing is a collective voice saying to me, you think this is not who we are? Yeah, it is. Wake up, dude. This is--
今天我不得不面对这样一个事实：也许这确实就是我们。我的意思是，你意识到6……是多少来着？你大概看过数据。十分之六或七的共和党人——我想一直以来都有十分之六的人同意我们应该禁止所有穆斯林进入美国。所以，也许这一切是一个集体的声音在对我说：你觉得这不是我们？是的，这就是我们。醒醒吧，伙计。这就是——
I have an atheist that calls me pretty regularly. And he gives me what for on the issues, particularly moral issues. But we've had some pretty good give-and-takes too, philosophically. But one of the questions he always puts to me is, how does it feel to be on the wrong side of history? And my answer has always been, a lot better than it would feel to be on the wrong side of eternity. My values are deeper than the culture of the moment.
有个无神论者经常给我打电话。他会在议题上，特别是在道德议题上质问我。但在哲学层面，我们也进行过一些不错的交流。他总是问我一个问题是：站在历史错误的一边是什么感觉？而我的回答总是：这比站在永恒错误的一边要好得多。我的价值观比当下的文化更深刻。
And I don't mean that in a-- golly, that sounded-- I don't mean that in an arrogant way. I mean it in a broken way that says, I realize that I may be swimming against the tide.
我不是以一种——天哪，那听起来——我不是以傲慢的方式说这句话。我是以一种心碎的方式说的，意思是，我意识到我可能是在逆流而上。
So are you a Republican?
那你现在还是共和党人吗？
Yeah, I'm still a Republican today because I haven't done anything about it. But it would break my heart to not be associated anymore. I mean, some people can just walk away. I mean, it would break my heart. But I'm not going to stay in the Republican Party if the Republican Party is not going to be conservative and it's not going to stand for traditional values.
是的，我今天还是共和党人，因为我还没做出什么改变。但如果不再和这个党派有联系，我会心碎的。我是说，有些人可以转头就走。对我来说这会心碎。但如果共和党不再保守，不再捍卫传统价值观，我就不会留在共和党内。
It's jarring when you're rolling along with a group of people, for years sometimes. They're like family. And then you hit this one dividing point that makes you think, wait, is that who we are? Because if that's who we are, what does that say about who I am? Even if the "we" is just you and one other person, it's hard. And that's what our show is about today, in two acts-- two families with two very different contentions. Stay with us.
当你和一群人一起前行时，有时一走就是几年。他们就像家人一样。然后你遇到了一个分歧点，让你想：等等，这就是我们吗？因为如果这就是我们，那说明我是什么样的人？即使这个“我们”只有你和另一个人，也很难。而这正是今天我们节目的主题，分两幕展开——两个家庭，有着两种完全不同的争论。请继续收听。
Act One, "Whose Great Idea was This?" This first story deals with something controversial that's covered now and then in the news. But this is the first time I've heard it talked about so personally as opposed to abstract and far away. It comes to us from Mariya Karimjee, and I'll let her explain what's at issue. But I just want to say here that, as Ira sometimes says, this story does acknowledge the existence of sex, and it probably isn't right for young kids. OK, here's Mariya.
第一幕，“这是谁的好主意？”第一个故事涉及现在新闻中时有报道的一个争议性话题。但这是我第一次听到有人如此私人地谈论它，而不是以一种抽象、遥远的方式。故事来自玛丽亚·卡里姆吉，我会让她来解释问题所在。但我在这里想先说明一点，正如艾拉有时所说，这个故事涉及性的存在，可能不适合年幼的孩子。好了，请听玛丽亚的讲述。
When I was in high school, my mother caught me reading a grocery store Harlequin novel in my room. She raised one eyebrow as I shoved it under the covers. It wasn't until weeks later, driving me somewhere, that she mentioned she'd seen it. I remember the firm line of her mouth as she explained that sex was almost never a good feeling. Don't go looking for that, she told me. That's almost never true.
高中时，我妈发现我在房间里看哈勒昆超市言情小说。当我把它塞到被子里时，她挑了挑眉。几周后，她开车送我的时候才提起这件事。我记得她解释说性几乎从来不是一种好的感受时，那坚定的嘴唇线条。别去寻找那个，她告诉我。那几乎从来不是真的。
I hadn't had sex, but I had started to wonder about it. My mother said that she thought, for men, it was the way that they described it in the books. For us, she said, it's different. At the time, I assumed that by "us" she meant women in general. Later I wondered if she meant her and me specifically.
我还没经历过性，但我开始好奇了。我妈说她觉得，对于男人来说，那是书里描述的那样。对我们来说，她说，情况不同。当时我以为她说的“我们”是指女性整体。后来我怀疑她是指她和我本人。
When I was seven years old and living in Karachi, Pakistan, my mother took me to the pediatrician. While I sat on a stool, polishing imaginary dirt off the buckles on my Mary Janes, my mother quietly asked if it was time for me to get the bug removed. According to my mother, a bug was growing in an egg down there-- her language, not mine-- and that it would hatch and eventually crawl to my brain unless we removed it, she said. My pediatrician agreed. It was time to see the woman who removes the bug.
我七岁时住在巴基斯坦卡拉奇，我妈带我去看了儿科医生。当我坐在凳子上，擦拭着玛丽珍鞋搭扣上的虚构灰尘时，我妈安静地问是否该给我把“虫子”取出来了。据我妈说，有个“虫子”在下面的蛋里生长——这是她的语言，不是我的——她说如果取不出来，它会孵化并最终爬到我的大脑里。儿科医生同意了。是时候去找那个取虫子的女人了。
A girl down the street that I'd grown up with had her bug removed, my grandmother told me. She was also seven, and after she came home from the operation, she felt fine, enough so to jump up and down on her bed. It was a story my grandmother told with enthusiasm. My older cousins, both girls, were each presented with a piece of gold jewelry when they returned home from their respective operations. Remembering this, I asked specifically for a simple gold chain with a teardrop pearl at the end.
我祖母告诉我，街上和我一起长大的一个女孩也取出了她的虫子。她当时也是七岁，手术后她感觉很好，甚至可以在床上跳来跳去。这是我祖母兴致勃勃讲的故事。我两个姐姐在各自手术回来后，都收到了一件金饰。想起这个，我特地要了一条简单的金链子，末端坠着一颗泪滴状珍珠。
I did not feel well enough to go around jumping on beds after my surgery. For two days, I wore what I can only describe as a big-girl diaper, wet with blood. Peeing was so painful that I tried to last for hours without going, until my mother explained that I could give myself an infection. For the next year, I'd break out into a cold sweat whenever I saw the kind-faced woman who, on a tarp on her living room floor, had spoken to me softly as she took a knife and cut me. I received the exact necklace I had requested and wore it all the time.
手术后我感觉不太好，无法去床上跳。两天里，我穿着所谓的“大号尿布”，上面湿透了血。撒尿太疼了，我甚至试过憋几个小时不去，直到我妈解释说这样会感染。接下来的日子里，每当看到那个面目慈祥的女人，只要想到她在客厅地板上的防水布上，用那种温柔的语气说话，同时拿出一把刀割开我，我就会冷汗直冒。我收到了我要求的项链，并一直戴着它。
Soon after my 11th birthday, my parents, brother, and I moved to Texas. The Houston area, where we lived, happened to have a decent number of Muslims from the same sect we belonged to in Pakistan. We're called Dawoodi Bohra.
我11岁生日后不久，父母、弟弟和我搬到了德克萨斯州。我们住的休斯顿地区，恰好有不少来自我们巴基斯坦教派的穆斯林。我们被称为“达伍迪波拉”教派。
But unlike many of the other immigrant families we knew, my parents wanted my brother and I to fully assimilate into the world we'd moved into. They encouraged us to sign up for any activities. They enrolled us in summer camps and group sports. My mom in particular really saw the benefit of raising me in the US. She was worried that in Karachi I'd always be in the shadow of my younger brother. Boys are valued more than girls in a lot of ways there.
但与我们认识的其他移民家庭不同，父母希望我和弟弟能完全融入这个我们移居的世界。他们鼓励我们报名参加各种活动。他们让我们参加夏令营和集体运动。尤其是妈妈，她真的看到了在美国养育我的好处。她担心如果待在卡拉奇，我永远会活在弟弟的阴影下。在那里，男孩在很多方面都比女孩受重视。
My family has always been close, but the move to the US cemented our closeness. But when I was 15, I overheard a woman at my mosque asking the woman next to her if her daughter had the operation already. Her question nudged something deep in my brain. Until that point, I honestly hadn't thought about my operation-- my bug. At that moment, the kind-faced woman came back to me. I could hear her comforting tone as she told me it would be over quickly.
我们家一直很亲近，移居美国加深了我们的亲密。但当我15岁时，我无意中听到清真寺里一个女人问旁边的人，她女儿做过那个手术了吗？她的问题触动了我脑海深处的某样东西。在那之前，我真的没想过我的手术——我的“虫子”。在那一刻，那个慈祥的女人重新浮现在我脑海。我能听到她安慰的语气，告诉我说很快就会结束的。
I'm not sure what I googled, but soon after returning home from mosque, I had words to describe what I thought had happened to me. Female genital cutting. Female genital circumcision. Clitorectomy. Female genital mutilation, or FGM.
我不确定我搜索了什么，但回家后不久，我就用词语描述了我想象中发生在我身上的事情。女性外生殖器切割。女性割礼。阴蒂切除术。女性生殖器残割，或称FGM。
I sat with my copy of Our Bodies, Ourselves that my American aunt had given me. The book has photos and diagrams of female genitalia, and suggests using a mirror to be able to see and understand your body better. Locked in my bathroom with a hand mirror between my legs, I realized that there was no diagram in the book that could explain what I saw. It was really confusing.
我坐在美国阿姨送我的《我们的身体，我们自己》一书前。书里有女性生殖器的照片和图示，并建议用镜子来观察和更好地了解自己的身体。躲在浴室里，把镜子放在双腿之间，我意识到书里没有任何图示能解释我看到的景象。这太让人困惑了。
Over the next few weeks, I continued searching for information on FGM online. Mainly I found articles about small tribal villages in Africa where girls sometimes had their labia sewn shut, and where infections, fistulas, and sometimes death could happen. I could see that what had happened to me was different from the cases I was reading about online.
在接下来的几周里，我继续在网上搜索关于FGM的信息。主要找到的是关于非洲小部落村庄的文章，女孩们的阴唇有时会被缝合，可能导致感染、瘘管，甚至死亡。我能看出，发生在我身上的事情与网上阅读的案例不同。
That's when I decided to search for FGM with the name of my particular sect, Dawoodi Bohra. One lonely academic article came up, titled "The Practice of Female Circumcision Among Bohra Muslims." That was it.
那时我决定搜索带有我们教派名称的FGM：达伍迪波拉。出现了一篇孤零零的学术文章，标题为《波拉穆斯林中的女性割礼习俗》。就是它。
Once I'd linked FGM to my culture, I was consumed by anger. I couldn't believe both that it had happened to me and that it had been completely ignored as a topic of discussion by my friends, by my religion, and above all by my own family. Why hadn't anyone said anything, especially my mother? She'd done this.
一旦我将FGM与我的文化联系起来，愤怒便吞噬了我。我无法相信，这件事发生在我身上，且被我的朋友、我的宗教，尤其是我的家人完全忽略并视为禁忌。为什么没有人提起，尤其是妈妈？是她让我经历的这些。
For the next several weeks, I didn't say anything to my mom about it. I'd go back and forth between being furious at her and remembering her cool hand on my forehead after I peed for the first time after being cut. When I finally brought it up, the two of us were cleaning my bathroom. I was standing in the tub, a roll of steel wool in my hand. I hadn't meant to talk to her about it, but I was angry-cleaning and running out of things to scrub.
随后的几周，我没跟妈妈提起这件事。我在对她的愤怒和回想起第一次手术后排尿时她在我额头上那双凉爽的手的温存记忆之间反复徘徊。当我最终提及时，我们俩正在清理浴室。我站在浴缸里，手里拿着一卷钢丝球。我本来没打算说，但我当时一边愤怒地清扫，一边快要没东西可刷了。
"What exactly was that bug thing you told me about?" My mother made a face I didn't recognize and didn't know how to interpret. First, I was terrified that my question made no sense, that I'd have to clarify further. Then I realized I was even more scared that it had made perfect sense.
“你跟我说的那个‘虫子’到底是什么？”妈妈做出了一个我无法识别也无法解读的表情。起初，我惊恐地想我的问题是不是毫无逻辑，我需要进一步阐述。然后我意识到，更让我害怕的是，我的问题竟然逻辑严密。
My mother's explanation came out as fumbled as my question, something about how women shouldn't be sexual, and shortening my clitoris. "You removed the part of me that makes me feel good while having sex?" I asked. I was 15 and armed with Our Bodies, Ourselves and some internet articles. I thought I knew. I thought I appreciated exactly what had been taken away from me. It'd take me another five years to realize I had no idea.
我妈的解释跟我当初的问题一样语无伦次，大致是说女人不该有性欲，所以要切除阴蒂。“你切除了我享受性快感的部分？”我问。我当时15岁，手头有《我们的身体，我们自己》和一些互联网文章。我想我懂了，我想我精确地评估了被剥夺的东西。又过了五年，我才意识到自己根本什么都不知道。
"I didn't have a choice," said my mother, "and it happened to me too. All seven-year-old Bohri girls have to go through this," she said. I slammed the door shut in her face and waited. She didn't try and open it back up.
“我没得选，”妈妈说，“我也经历了同样的事情。所有七岁的波拉女孩都必须经历这个，”她说。我摔门而去，关在门外等着。她没有试着把门打开。
I couldn't understand how my mother-- the woman who made sure I got all the same opportunities as my brother, who cried when I told her I needed a training bra for gym and then got me one anyway, who attended every free seminar about preparing her children for college-- how could she be the same person who'd watched as a stranger cut me? I learned what it was like to love someone without forgiving them.
我无法理解我妈妈——那个确保我拥有和弟弟同样机会的女人，那个在我说需要健身用的运动内衣时哭着给我买来的女人，那个参加每一个为孩子准备大学申请免费研讨会的女人——怎么会是看着陌生人对我动刀的那个人？我学会了什么是不用原谅去爱一个人。
My college roommate and I would never be close. One night, as I highlighted a sociology text, my roommate asked me if I masturbated. I sputtered, "no." "You should try it," she told me. She moved off her twin bed and onto the corner of mine. "Don't be so prude," she said when I cringed.
大学室友和我从不亲近。一天晚上，我正在用荧光笔标记社会学课本时，室友问我是否自慰。我结结巴巴地说：“没有。”“你应该试试，”她告诉我。她从单人床上移到了我的床角。“别那么保守，”当我畏缩时，她说。
I attended a small all-women's liberal arts college in western Massachusetts, Mount Holyoke, and it was a far cry from the conservative, Baptist, perfectly-coiffed Texas girls I knew as friends in high school. I could never really confide in them.
我就读于马萨诸塞州西部的一所小型女子文理学院——曼荷莲学院，那和我高中时认识的保守、浸信会、发型精致的德州女孩们大相径庭。我永远无法真正向她们倾诉。
But to my college roommate, I inexplicably opened up. I told her everything I could think of. I confessed that I had no idea what it meant to have a clitorectomy, that I had no idea of the extent of the damage. I explained about the girls in the African villages and the pictures of their labia sewn shut, making clear that this wasn't my situation. She smoothed my back, chewing on her lip.
但不知何故，我向室友敞开了心扉。我告诉了她我能想到的一切。我承认我根本不知道阴蒂切除意味着什么，不知道伤害的程度。我解释了非洲村庄女孩的情况，以及她们阴唇被缝合的照片，明确那不是我的情况。她抚摸着我的背，咬着嘴唇。
In the months that followed, we didn't get closer. We never talked like that again. Every few days, though, she encouraged me to go see a gynecologist at the school. Before going home for the summer, I made an appointment at student health services. 20 minutes after walking in, I was in stirrups.
随后的几个月里，我们并没有更亲密。我们再也没进行过那种谈话。不过，每隔几天，她都会鼓励我去看学校的妇科医生。暑假回家前，我预约了学生健康中心。走进诊室20分钟后，我就躺上了检查台。
If you're listening right now with small children, they may not want to hear this next part. When the doctor finally arrived, she sat down between my legs, murmuring something about a pap smear. "Let's have a look," she said. I clamped my knees together and started bawling.
如果您现在带着年幼的孩子收听，他们可能不想听接下来的部分。医生终于来到时，她坐在我的双腿之间，喃喃地说着关于巴氏涂片的事情。“我们来看看，”她说。我紧紧并拢双膝，开始嚎啕大哭。
The doctor didn't miss a beat. "Why don't you sit right up, and let's talk about any questions you may have." She had questions of her own too. "When did this happen?" "How long did it hurt?" "Are you able to wipe yourself with toilet paper without discomfort?"
医生表现得非常冷静。“你为什么不坐起来，我们来聊聊你可能有的疑问。”她自己也有疑问。“这是什么时候发生的？”“痛了多久？”“你用卫生纸擦拭时会有不适吗？”
The doctor admitted up front that she didn't know much, but said that taking a closer look might help her out. When I finally let her examine me, she let out a long, low breath. For a few long moments, she looked without speaking. Then she asked me for my cell number. She would ask around, see if anyone in the area knew more than she did.
医生坦诚她了解不多，但说仔细检查可能会有帮助。当我最终同意让她检查时，她发出了一声长长的、沉闷的叹息。沉默了好一会儿，她观察着，没说话。然后她问我要了手机号。她会四处打听，看看周边有没有人比她更了解情况。
"What I can tell you is that there's a lot of thin scar tissue," she said. "This doesn't look like a full clitorectomy," she added, explaining that while she'd never seen one before, it looked like a partial cut. "Did a medical professional do this?" she asked. I didn't know, I admitted.
“我可以告诉你的是，有很多薄薄的疤痕组织，”她说。“这看起来不像完全切除，”她补充道，解释说虽然她以前从未见过这种情况，但这看起来像是部分切除。“这是专业医护人员做的吗？”她问。我承认我不知道。
The question would linger with me, and for months I would weigh the consequences of asking my mother. Later, after I put my clothes on, she came back in to hug me. "Come see me anytime with any questions," she said. And before I could stop myself, I blurted out, can I ever have an orgasm? She handed me a few printed pamphlets on healthy masturbation.
这个问题萦绕在我心头，几个月里我一直权衡着问妈妈的后果。后来，穿好衣服后，她回来拥抱我。“随时回来找我咨询任何问题，”她说。我还没来得及阻止自己，就脱口而出：我还能达到性高潮吗？她递给我几本关于健康自慰的印刷册子。
I figured out that getting to orgasm wasn't going to be easy. Even when I tried, any wrong move, any sudden accidental movement, would shoot an incredible pain inside of me. I hardly ever mention this-- to anyone. Even when friends who knew my secret talked about sex, I would pretend I was just like them. I'd assure them that I was hooking up randomly with people, same as they were. It's ridiculous, I know, but I didn't know what to do.
我明白了想要达到性高潮并不容易。即使我想尝试，任何错误的动作，任何突发的意外挪动，都会带给我内部难以置信的痛苦。我几乎从不提起这件事——对任何人。即使是知道我秘密的朋友谈论性时，我也假装自己和她们一样。我会向她们保证我也像她们一样随便和人发生关系。我知道这很荒谬，但我不知道该怎么办。
When I finally started dating, it would take me months to let my boyfriend know why we weren't progressing past second base. In his dorm room in DC, I took three shots of green apple vodka and then blurted out as much as I could. My boyfriend silently listened, holding my hands as I spoke. He didn't ask questions or try to break up with me. He told me he would wait until I was ready. I wondered if I would ever be ready.
当我终于开始约会时，花了好几个月我才告诉男友为什么我们无法进展到二垒。在华盛顿他的宿舍里，我连喝了三杯青苹果伏特加，然后把我知道的尽可能多地倾诉了出来。男友默默地听着，在我讲述时紧紧握着我的手。他没有问问题，也没打算跟我分手。他告诉我，他会等到我准备好的那一天。我怀疑自己是否永远准备不好。
After a year of dating him, I decided that I needed to get it over with. I broached the subject with my boyfriend. I wanted to have sex before the end of the summer. I don't want you to stop, even if I look like it's hurting me, I told him. He grimaced, but I repeated the statement again and then again.
交往一年后，我决定必须结束这种状态。我向男友提起了这个话题。我想在暑假结束前发生关系。我告诉他：我不想让你停下来，即使我看起来很痛苦。他皱了皱眉，但我又重复了一遍，接着又说了一遍。
So one night, I drank a half a bottle of wine in 15 minutes as my boyfriend watched warily. For a blissful 45 minutes, we made out on the couch, his hands staying in all of the safe spots, the ones that months of dating had taught him didn't make me clench up. The wine turned my limbs heavy.
所以一个晚上，男友警惕地看着我，我在15分钟内喝掉了半瓶酒。在接下来的45分钟里，我们在沙发上亲热，他的手一直停在所有安全的位置，那些几个月的交往让他知道不会让我紧绷的位置。酒精让我的四肢变得沉重。
We moved from the couch to the bed. I closed my eyes, counting to control my heartbeat and the nausea welling up inside me. Technically, we began having sex. Pain shot up my body. I could feel it in my teeth and in the muscles of my jaw. My insides felt like they were being sandpapered. The pain was everywhere. We didn't continue. My boyfriend kissed my forehead, reminded me he loved me, and left for the bathroom. I sat in the bed and cried.
我们从沙发移到了床上。我闭上眼，数数来控制心跳和内心涌起的恶心感。技术上来说，我们开始性交了。疼痛冲过我的身体。我能感觉到牙齿和下巴肌肉都在疼。身体内部感觉像是被砂纸打磨。疼痛无处不在。我们没能继续。男友亲了亲我的额头，提醒我他爱我，然后去了浴室。我坐在床上哭了起来。
I was still crying when my boyfriend came out of the bathroom. He took one look at me and then told me he was heading out to our favorite neighborhood bar. I know that sounds callous, but he knew that in moments of distress, I rarely wanted to be comforted.
男友从浴室出来时，我还在哭。他看我一眼，然后告诉我他要出门去我们最喜欢的社区酒吧。我知道这听起来很无情，但他知道在情绪困扰时，我很少需要安慰。
Then I called my mother. "Is sex ever good for you?" I asked her. There was a brief but important pause. I heard the click of a door and then her voice, clear, unmuffled. "Excuse me?" she asked. "I tried to have sex with my boyfriend," I said. "It didn't go well. It hurt so bad that I'm not sure I ever want to try it again. I know you don't think I should be having sex, but I'm so scared."
然后我给妈妈打了电话。“你觉得性生活好吗？”我问她。一阵短暂但重要的停顿。我听到了门关上的咔哒声，接着是她的声音，清晰，不含糊。“你说什么？”她问。“我试着和男友发生关系，”我说。“过程很糟糕。太疼了，我不知道以后还想不想尝试。我知道你不认为我该发生关系，但我真的很害怕。”
What I didn't say out loud, but what my mother instinctively knew, was what I was so scared of. It wasn't just that I was scared of sex but that because of that, true love would escape me forever, that I was unlovable.
我没有大声说出来，但妈妈本能地知道我在害怕什么。不仅是因为我害怕性，而且是因为正因如此，真爱将永远离我而去，我是不可爱的。
She told me about how when she was a teenager, she saved up pocket change for Harlequin romances. All I wanted was to figure out how to feel like those women, she told me. She also told me how when she was with my dad, if he moved too fast, she'd feel sharp pain. I knew exactly what she was talking about, pain that suffocated any of the good. "I get panic attacks when that happens," I told her. "I did too," she told me. "Your father and I talked through what felt good, and we figured out a way," she explained.
她告诉我她青少年时期如何积攒零花钱买哈勒昆浪漫小说。她告诉我，她只想弄清楚如何感受到书里那些女人的感觉。她还告诉我，她和爸爸在一起时，如果他动作太快，她会感到剧痛。我完全明白她在说什么，那是压倒一切愉悦的疼痛。“当那种情况发生时，我会惊恐发作，”我告诉她。“我也一样，”她对我说。“你父亲和我谈论过什么感觉好，我们找到了方法，”她解释说。
It was a good conversation. I told my mother that I loved her. I kept wanting her to apologize for giving me the same pain that she herself had suffered, but she stayed quiet. As we said our goodbyes and were about to hang up, she suddenly said, unprompted, "I hate everyone else too. Those women on TV who love sex, who enjoy it, I hate them too."
那是一次不错的对话。我告诉妈妈我爱她。我一直希望她能为让我承受了她自己也遭受过的痛苦而道歉，但她保持了沉默。在挂断电话前的告别时刻，她突然不假思索地说道：“我也讨厌所有人。电视上那些热爱性、享受性的女人，我也讨厌她们。”
Since that first experience with a gynecologist in college, I've been to a handful of other doctors. Many of them hadn't seen anyone who'd been cut before. When I'd peppered them with questions, they seemed hesitant to respond with authority. Only once since my college ex did I hook up with anyone again-- try to hook up, that is. It too went badly.
自从大学第一次看妇科医生后，我又看了几位医生。她们中许多人从未见过被切割过的患者。当我追问她们时，她们似乎很犹豫，无法给予权威的回应。自从大学那次约会后，我只再和人发生过一次关系——我是说，尝试过。那次也进行得很糟。
That time prompted me to take action. I visited a doctor who specialized in victims of FGM. I was living without health insurance that year. And when I called her office explaining this, the receptionist told me to plan to spend somewhere around $2,000 for the consult. It was all of my savings.
那次经历促使我采取了行动。我拜访了一位专门研究FGM受害者的医生。那年我没有医疗保险。当我给她的诊室打电话解释情况时，接待员告诉我要为咨询费用预留大约2000美元。那是我所有的积蓄。
The money was worth it. This doctor, unlike so many of the gynecologists I'd seen before, didn't wince when she peered between my legs. She didn't over-apologize or pat my knees. She didn't murmur in a hushed whisper, like the medical resident at Columbia, "oh, bless your dear heart." Instead, she silently examined me. She'd heard of the religious sect that I belong to and had examined other girls like me.
钱花得值。这位医生，不像我之前看过的许多妇科医生，在窥视我的双腿之间时没有畏缩。她没有过度道歉或拍我的膝盖。她没有像哥伦比亚大学的住院医生那样低声私语：“噢，天哪，祝福你亲爱的。”相反，她静静地检查了我。她听说过我所属的宗教教派，也检查过其他像我一样的女孩。
She explained that because the cutting is done in the living room without proper medical equipment, for girls in my sect, the results varied. Some of the girls can easily go on to have great sex lives. But for me, the main difference was in the extensive scar tissue and the nerve damage.
她解释说，因为切割是在客厅里完成的，没有专业的医疗设备，所以我们教派女孩的情况各不相同。有些女孩可以轻松地继续拥有美满的性生活。但对我来说，主要的区别在于广泛的疤痕组织和神经损伤。
I'd read of a surgery where a doctor was grafting other genital tissue as part of a regenerative process. I asked her about it. She shook her head. "I wouldn't recommend this," she said. "The science was unreliable."
我读过一种手术，医生可以通过移植其他生殖器组织作为再生过程的一部分。我问她关于这个手术。她摇了摇头。“我不建议这么做，”她说。“科学上不可靠。”
She told me what I'd long suspected. I'd probably never have a wonderful, easy, uncomplicated sex life. Instead, sex for me would likely involve many careful conversations with my partner, a sex therapist, and a willingness to trust a human beyond what I could imagine.
她告诉我我早已怀疑的事情。我可能永远不会拥有美好、轻松、无复杂的性生活。相反，对我来说，性可能需要与伴侣、性治疗师进行多次谨慎的沟通，并且需要比我能想象的更进一步去信任人类。
I wasn't horribly mutilated or defective in a way that made me incapable of enjoying sex. She explained, "this is not terminal. This is not a life sentence. Find a sex therapist you trust. Learn to allow yourself to let go." I wasn't sure what she meant and didn't ask further questions. In the moments after she gave me her verdict, she mentioned a support group she held at Brigham and Women's Hospital. I nodded enthusiastically, knowing I'd never attend.
我没有被严重摧残或以某种方式导致我无法享受性快感。她解释说：“这不是绝症。这不是无期徒刑。找一个你信任的性治疗师。学会让自己放开。”我不确定她是什么意思，没再问问题。在给出结论后的片刻，她提到了她在布莱根和妇女医院举办的支持小组。我热切地点着头，心里却知道我永远不会去参加。
A few years ago, I moved back to Karachi for work. My parents had moved back while I was in college. Here's a quick little explainer about Karachi, just so you know what to picture. Karachi is a huge city with around 22 million people. It's modern, and it's not. It has gleaming, gorgeous, multi-story malls and large movie theaters that play the latest Hollywood and Bollywood films. People are on Tinder.
几年前，我为了工作搬回了卡拉奇。父母在我大学期间搬了回去。这里有一个关于卡拉奇的快速小介绍，让你知道画面是什么样的。卡拉奇是一个拥有2200万人口的超级大城市。它既现代，又不现代。它有闪亮、华丽的多层购物中心和播放最新好莱坞与宝莱坞电影的大型电影院。人们也在用Tinder。
Karachi also gets listed as among the most dangerous mega cities in the world. There's no international tourism. There's beggars at almost every street corner and piles of burning trash pretty much everywhere in the city, even the really nice areas.
卡拉奇也被列为世界上最危险的特大城市之一。这里没有国际旅游业。每个街角几乎都有乞丐，而且几乎随处可见燃烧的垃圾堆，即使在非常好的地区也是如此。
The Dawoodi Bohra sect, which I'm from, is a small, typically pretty well-off minority in Karachi. There's about 40,000 of us. I live in a neighborhood made up entirely of other Bohris.
我出身的达伍迪波拉教派在卡拉奇是一个人数较少、通常较富裕的少数群体。我们大约有4万人。我住在一个完全由波拉人组成的社区。
Readjusting to life in Karachi as an adult was difficult. I reluctantly attended services at the same mosque I went to as a kid. I'd sit there and scan all of the faces to see if I could recognize the woman who had cut me. But then I realized that seated beside me were at least 100 other girls who had likely also been cut. I wondered what their sex lives were like. I'd sit fidgeting, wondering if any of them had escaped the cutting.
作为成年人重新适应卡拉奇的生活很困难。我勉强参加了儿时去过的同一家清真寺的礼拜。我会坐在那里扫视所有人的脸，看看能不能认出那个给我动刀的女人。但随后我意识到，坐在我旁边的至少还有100个女孩，她们很可能也经历过同样的切割。我好奇她们的性生活是什么样的。我会烦躁不安地坐着，想知道她们中是否有人逃过了切割。
So I started asking women in Karachi to talk to me about this. Half of the women I asked said no. This woman said yes.
所以我开始请求卡拉奇的女性和我聊这个话题。我问过的一半女性拒绝了。这个女人答应了。
I mean, whatever I can answer, I will.
我是说，我能回答的，我都会回答。
Are you nervous?
你紧张吗？
Not so much.
没那么紧张。
This is a friend of mine from childhood. She asked that I not use her real name, so I'm going to call her Sameena. Sameena is 27. We were friends when we were very young, but we didn't stay in touch after I moved to the US.
这是一位我儿时的朋友。她要求我不要用真名，所以我就叫她萨米娜。萨米娜27岁。我们很小的时候是朋友，但我搬到美国后我们就没联系了。
We sat and talked on my bedroom floor. Sameena said she'd been cut too. Unlike me, though, she knew the woman who did it. She was a distant relative.
我们坐在我卧室的地板上聊天。萨米娜说她也经历过切割。不过与我不同，她认识那个动手的人。那是她的一位远房亲戚。
I remember that we were in her drawing room. I was lying on the floor. I think my mom was holding me. And she was holding my legs, and my mom must have been holding my arms and stuff. There was no-- I don't remember what equipment she used. Was it a blade or something else? I don't remember. She cut something.
我记得我们在她的客厅里。我躺在地板上。我想是我妈抱着我。她按住我的腿，我妈一定是在按住我的手臂之类的。没有——我不记得她用了什么器械。是刀还是别的什么？我不记得了。她割了点东西。
Do you remember it hurting?
你记得疼吗？
I think so, yes, enough that I was screaming and crying. And then she put a bandage over it. And then she had this huge scissor, and I thought she was cutting something else again. She was bringing like a huge-ass scissors, so I screamed and I jumped. And then my mom held me and all of that. And then she said in Gujarati that she's cutting the bandage, not me again. And then she gave me candy.
我想是的，很疼，疼到我一直在尖叫哭泣。然后她贴上了一块绷带。她还有一把巨大的剪刀，我以为她又要割什么东西了。她拿着像巨大剪刀一样的东西，所以我尖叫着跳了起来。我妈抱住了我。然后她用古吉拉特语说，她在割绷带，不是又割我。然后她给了我一颗糖。
And then I came home. And I knew that something had been cut, but obviously I didn't know why because we never spoke about it with friends and stuff. I mean, my mom told me, don't talk about it. I was told it was a bug. It was a bug. It's gone. You don't have it anymore. Chapter closed.
然后我回家了。我知道有些地方被割了，但显然我不知道为什么，因为我们从不和朋友提起这种事。我是说，我妈告诉我，别提这件事。我被告知那是只“虫子”。那是只虫子。它没了。你再也没有它了。篇章翻过去了。
The bug story. I had thought that was specific to my family. Like me, Sameena figured out on her own what had been done to her. When she was 17, she read a change.org petition asking Bohris to ban clitorectomies. Almost every Bohri I know has seen it. Sameena thought it was probably drafted and circulated by Bohris who weren't as devout as she was. Why are they questioning this? she thought. Then she did the same thing I did. She asked her mother about it.
虫子的故事。我曾以为那是我们家特有的。像我一样，萨米娜自己搞清楚了在她身上发生了什么。17岁时，她读到了Change.org上的一份请愿书，呼吁波拉人禁止阴蒂切除术。我认识的几乎每个波拉人都看过它。萨米娜认为这可能是由那些不像她那么虔诚的波拉人起草并传播的。为什么他们会质疑这个？她想。然后她做了和我一样的事。她问了她妈妈。
My intention was not to speak to her in detail and ask her why she did it or why did they have to do it. It was like [GUJARATI], the quick question, why do we do it? And then she said, to curb the sexual desire of women so that they don't cheat and they don't get horny and sleep around. And she didn't use these words, but she said that this is why we do it, to curb your sexual desire.
我的意图并不是要和她详细谈论并质问她为什么这么做，或者他们为什么要这么做。那就像是一次简短的质问：为什么我们要这样做？然后她说，是为了克制女性的性欲，这样她们就不会出轨，不会变得欲火焚身，到处和人乱搞。她没用这些词，但她说这就是我们做这件事的原因，为了克制你的性欲。
Were you surprised by her answer?
她的回答让你惊讶吗？
I wasn't surprised as such. I just felt like it was unfair. Why do you want to stop me from having casual sex? Why not men? So I think that's what I thought at that point, but I still don't remember feeling angry.
算不上惊讶。我只是觉得这不公平。为什么你要阻止我进行随意的性行为？为什么不限制男性？所以我想这就是我当时的想法，但我依然不记得有感到愤怒。
That was 10 years ago. She feels differently now.
那是10年前的事了。她现在感觉不同了。
Right now I do feel some anger that this is done. I had a huge argument with my parents and, well, it didn't end up anywhere.
现在我确实对这种习俗感到愤怒。我和父母大吵了一架，嗯，没吵出什么结果。
When was this argument?
那次争论是什么时候？
Recent.
最近。
Recent as in February of this year, three months ago. When she says this, I know exactly what prompted the argument. It was my brother.
最近是指今年二月，三个月前。当她说这话时，我知道是什么引发了那场争论。是我弟弟。
In February, he spoke out against FGM, female genital mutilation, at a panel at the UN. We were asked to do the panel together, but I was out of the country, so he did it alone. He sat at a long, curved conference table in a stately room with wood walls. He was one of five people who spoke that day. It was videotaped.
二月时，他在联合国的一个小组会议上公开反对FGM，即女性生殖器残割。我们要一起参加那个小组，但我当时在国外，所以他一个人去了。他坐在一间带有木墙的庄严会议室里，在那张长长的弧形会议桌旁。他是那天发言的五个人之一。会议录了像。
"So many women in my life that I was close to had gone through this. And I was just shocked. I was in denial. I was frustrated. It's been over the last five to six years since then that I've really become involved in this movement."
“我生命中许多与我亲近的女性都经历过这一切。我简直惊呆了。我一直处于否认状态。我感到非常挫败。过去五到六年来，我才真正投入到这场运动中。”
My brother learned about FGM in his college anthropology class. He thought it was something that happened in rural African villages. He had no idea about me or our mom and grandmothers. Then a Bohri girl at college set him straight, and he called me immediately, saying, "why didn't you tell me?"
我弟弟是在大学人类学课上了解到FGM的。他以为这只是发生在非洲乡村的小事。他根本不知道发生在我身上，以及我们妈妈和祖母身上的事。后来大学里一个波拉女孩让他看清了真相，他立刻打电话给我，说：“你为什么不告诉我？”
After he spoke at the UN, he posted about it on Facebook. It's a long, passionate post where he urges Bohri men not to stay silent and condone FGM. In the post, he says, "FGM is not simply a women's issue, but a human rights issue. Men must start seeing it as such," and that "FGM has absolutely no place in Islam. There's nothing in the Quran about it."
在联合国发言后，他在Facebook上发了贴。那是一篇长篇且充满激情的文章，敦促波拉男性不要保持沉默并纵容FGM。在文中，他说：“FGM不仅是女性问题，更是人权问题。男性必须开始这样看待它。”他还说：“FGM在伊斯兰教中绝无容身之地。古兰经里对此只字未提。”
The video of my brother's speech made the rounds in the Bohri community. On Facebook, there was only a show of support. Bohris from around the world Liked my brother's stance on FGM.
我弟弟演讲的视频在波拉社区传开了。在Facebook上，只有支持的声音。来自世界各地的波拉人点赞了我弟弟反对FGM的立场。
But less publicly, my brother had sparked some controversy. His private message folder filled up with messages from Bohris who disagreed. My parents received texts from Bohri friends in Pakistan, Tanzania, the UK, and the US, warning them that they may get in trouble with the clergy for this. A high-ranking clergy member's wife strongly discouraged me from attending further services at my mosque. Like a lot of Bohris in Karachi, Sameena saw my brother's post and showed it to her parents.
但私下里，我弟弟引发了一些争议。他的私人留言箱里充满了不同意这一立场的波拉人发来的信息。我父母收到了来自巴基斯坦、坦桑尼亚、英国和美国的波拉朋友发来的短信，警告他们可能会因为这件事在教职人员那里惹上麻烦。一位高级教职人员的妻子强烈劝阻我不要继续参加清真寺的礼拜。像卡拉奇的许多波拉人一样，萨米娜看到了我弟弟的贴子，并把它给父母看了。
And with this, when I told my mom that I saw this on Facebook, my mom specifically told me not to Like it. She said, don't Like it. Don't share it.
就是这样，当我告诉我妈我在Facebook上看到了这个，我妈特地告诉我不许点赞。她说，别点赞。别分享。
We were at home. My dad was there as well. This is what my dad said, that your sexual desire, you have to curb it just so that the girls don't go around. And so I said, but guys do it. My mom was like, why don't you question [GUJARATI] then? Why don't you question [GUJARATI]? Why are you questioning this? I was like, because it's being done to me!
我们当时在家。我爸也在场。这就是我爸说的，你的性欲，你必须克制它，这样女孩就不会乱来。所以我说，但男人们也乱来啊。我妈就说，那你为什么不去质疑伊斯兰的教义呢？为什么要质疑这个？我说：因为这是发生在我身上的！
Quick translation. Sameena's mom basically argued, why not question everything we believe then? Praying five times a day. Fasting. Every major tenet of Islam. As Sameena pointed out, none of those things are an assault on her body. Anyhow, Sameena's fight with her parents went on.
简短翻译一下。萨米娜的妈妈基本上反驳说：那为什么不质疑我们相信的一切呢？每天祈祷五次。禁食。伊斯兰教的每一项主要信条。正如萨米娜指出的，这些事情都没有对她的身体造成侵害。总之，萨米娜和父母的争吵还在继续。
And then I was like, if having sex is a bad thing, and if you don't want me to do it, teach me not to do it like you taught me not to drink and eat pork. I don't do it, right? Similarly, if you will have taught me not to sleep around, I probably wouldn't. I mean, if consciously I have controlled myself, that's the point in Islam, to have that willpower to not do something. I would never eat pork because I've been told all my life, you're not supposed to eat it. I'm never going to eat it.
然后我说，如果性行为是一件坏事，如果你们不希望我做，那就教导我别做，就像教我别喝酒吃猪肉一样。我不做那事，对吧？同样，如果你们教我不乱搞，我大概也就不会了。我是说，如果我自觉地克制自己，那才是伊斯兰教的意义所在，拥有不去做某事的意志力。我永远不会吃猪肉，因为我从小被教育我不该吃。我永远不会吃。
The point is, I know this is something that I'm not supposed to do. If you told us what we were doing to ourselves, and then had done it with consent, then it's a different thing. But at an age where I don't know what it is, you do something to me which is irreversible. And you don't have to cut something off just to curb that desire.
重点是，我知道这是我不该做的事。如果你们告诉我们我们正对自己做什么，然后我们达成共识，那是另一回事。但在一个我根本不知道这是什么的年纪，你们在我身上做了不可逆转的事情。而且为了克制那种欲望，并不非得切掉什么东西。
Well, what did they say back to that specific argument?
嗯，他们对那个具体的观点有什么回应？
Um--
嗯——
Because I feel like it's a really good argument. You're like, OK, you've taught me right from wrong. So why is sex something that you didn't teach me? You just made a decision for me.
因为我觉得这是一个非常好的观点。你说，好吧，你们教了我什么是对，什么是错。所以为什么性行为是你们没教我的东西？你们只是替我做了一个决定。
I knew they did not have a response because, well, what do you say to your child who is asking you such a question? Because I'm not even sure if they knew why exactly they were doing it.
我知道他们没有回应，因为，你能对提出这种问题的孩子说什么呢？因为我甚至不确定他们是否知道自己为什么要这么做。
Did you feel like you'd won that argument?
你觉得你赢了那场争论吗？
I think so, yes.
我想是的，没错。
Do you think they thought that you'd won that argument?
你觉得他们认为你赢了那场争论吗？
I think so. They didn't have an answer. Then my mom was like, well, I also pierced your ears, but you didn't say anything about that.
我想是的。他们答不上来。然后我妈就说：嗯，我也给你打了耳洞，但你没说什么。
My mom said the same thing. She literally said the same thing. I was like, how is piercing my ears at six months old anything like getting my clitoris cut? Are you crazy? I cannot believe you would say that.
我妈也是这么说的。她真的是原话照搬。我说：在我六个月大时打耳洞，怎么能和切除阴蒂相提并论？你们疯了吗？我无法相信你会这么说。
I know.
我知道。
Did that make you mad?
那让你生气吗？
I was super mad, yes.
我超级生气，是的。
The thing I really wanted to know, though, was much more personal. It was the question that had been haunting me from the moment I found out that I had been cut. My question centered on the very thing her parents told her was the goal of FGM, curbing women's desire.
但我真正想知道的是，要个人化得多。那是从我发现自己被切割那一刻起就一直困扰我的问题。我的问题集中在她的父母告诉她FGM的目标上，即克制女性的欲望。
I definitely feel desire. I'm just kind of wondering, is that true of you? Do you get turned on?
我确实感觉到欲望。我只是有点好奇，你也是这样吗？你会感到兴奋吗？
I do.
是的。
You do get turned on?
你真的会感到兴奋？
I do. Usually-- I mean, mostly if I'm watching something sexy. Then yeah, I do. So every time I watch TV or something and I get turned on, and then I think about what my parents said, that you don't feel any sexual desire, here I'm thinking that they said that when you get cut, you don't feel any desire. But I am feeling it, so maybe this kind of circumcision, it's not affecting me.
会。通常——我是说，如果我看到什么性感的东西。那时是的，我会。所以每次我看电视之类的东西并感到兴奋时，我就想到父母说的话，说你不会有任何性欲。我当时的理解是，他们说当你被切割后，你就不会有任何欲望。但我现在正感觉着，所以也许这种割礼，并没有影响到我。
Sameena's not married, and she hasn't had sex. She's also not in pain the same way I am.
萨米娜还没结婚，也没有发生过性行为。她也没有像我这样痛苦。
Have you ever tried to masturbate?
你试过自慰吗？
I have.
试过。
And how'd that go for you?
感觉怎么样？
It works.
挺好的。
Well hey, that's so nice to hear. There is hope out there.
嘿，听到这个真好。外面还是有希望的。
Yeah. The thing is, I've never spoken to anyone in detail who has had sex about how it feels and stuff, so I don't know. And I haven't spoken to anyone who has been cut and has had sex. That is the thing.
是啊。问题是，我从未和任何有过性行为的人详细聊过感觉如何之类的话题，所以我不知道。而且我还没和任何同样被切割且发生过性行为的人聊过。这就是问题所在。
Knowing that I've been cut, I can still masturbate. And I keep thinking that OK, maybe this is like a lesser level of orgasm or whatever feeling that I get. Maybe I don't feel as much desire as people who were not cut. Maybe if they hadn't done it, I would feel more desire than what I feel right now, maybe.
知道自己被切割后，我依然可以自慰。但我一直在想，好吧，也许这只是较低水平的性高潮，或者无论我得到的是什么感觉。也许我感受到的欲望没有没被切割的人多。也许如果他们没那样做，我会比现在感受到更多欲望，也许吧。
I told Sameena that I thought the whole idea of curbing desire is a myth and BS, and that saying that cutting limits a woman's desire is just a way to hide what the goal really is-- to take away our enjoyment of sex. Sameena didn't entirely agree.
我告诉萨米娜，我认为克制欲望的整体理念是一个神话，是胡扯。而且声称切割限制女性欲望只是为了掩盖真正的目标——剥夺我们享受性的权利。萨米娜并不完全同意。
But I don't think that taking something away from us is their intention, because they're doing it without reason. I think for most parents-- like I know my friends' parents as well. I see my mom in each one of them. Their mothers and stuff, they're all like [GUJARATI].
但我认为夺走我们的东西并不是他们的本意，因为他们做这件事时没理由。我想对大多数父母来说——就像我也认识我朋友的父母一样。我在她们每个人身上都看到了我妈的影子。她们的母亲什么的，她们都……
[GUJARATI]. It's a part of our culture, her mom said.
[古吉拉特语]
So they just do it without any reason, I guess. I mean, there's really not much logic. When you believe in something blindly, that's what they call faith. If everybody in the community is doing something, then it's something that you just do. I feel like it's like-- I don't know how to put this into words. My mother was the one who took me and did this to me. So I don't know if it's like a male-dominated thing, or if men don't want this for women, or if it's like just women have just taught themselves that they shouldn't enjoy this or something. I don't know if I'm making sense.
[古吉拉特语]。这是我们文化的一部分，她妈妈说。
You're making perfect sense.
所以我想她们就是没理由地做了，我想。我是说，确实没什么逻辑。当你盲目地相信某样东西时，那就是所谓的信仰。如果社区里的每个人都在做某事，那你就跟着做。我觉得这就像——我不知道怎么用言语表达。是我妈妈带我去并对我做了这件事。所以我不知道这是否是一件男性主导的事情，或者男性不希望女性享受这个，或者仅仅是女性教会了自己不该享受这些东西。我不知道我表达得对不对。
OK.
你表达得非常清楚。
She was making perfect sense. I had wondered the same thing. Why were women still subjecting their daughters to this? Until recently, my grandmother didn't even know what the term FGM meant. Out of the blue, she asked me to explain it. She read about it in the paper.
好。
This time I told her about the bug story. I asked her if she remembered when I was cut and told her how wrong I thought the practice was. I asked her if she thought it was wrong. She mumbled something about the religious clergy wanting it done, and that she supposed they knew best. I was stunned. She seemed to have no idea what the surgery did exactly, what it took away. Before I left, my grandmother held my hand and said, "your mother tried to stop it."
她表达得非常清楚。我也一直在想同样的问题。为什么女性还在让她们的女儿经历这种事？直到最近，我祖母甚至不知道FGM这个词的意思。突如其来地，她让我解释一下。她在报纸上读到过。
I didn't understand. I couldn't even process what she'd said. It took me weeks to speak to my mother about that conversation I'd had with my grandmother. When I finally did, it was so hard to bring up, I just whispered to my mom, "did you try and stop them from cutting me?"
这次我给她讲了虫子的故事。我问她是否记得我被切割的时候，并告诉她我觉得这种做法有多错误。我问她是否认为这是错的。她含糊其辞，说宗教教职人员想要这样做，她猜他们最清楚。我惊呆了。她似乎根本不知道手术到底做了什么，夺走了什么。离开前，我祖母握着我的手说：“你妈妈尝试过阻止。”
She explained it was my grandfather who had insisted that the women in the family be cut. He believed that if the religious clergy thought this was necessary, we were wrong to question it. The fights about having me cut grew so out of control that he threatened to kick my mother out of the family. My grandmother was silent about it all. After my mother told me what really happened, our relationship changed. My anger towards her was gone almost immediately.
我不明白。我甚至无法处理她说的话。花了几个星期，我才和我妈谈起我和祖母的那次谈话。最终谈及时，这太难开口了，我只是低声对妈妈说：“你当时试着阻止他们切割我了吗？”
I wish I could tell you definitively that things are changing among Bohris. Mainly because of the secrecy, people don't really say where they stand. After my brother spoke at the UN, my father was proud of him. He apologized to me for what happened. He said it's like if someone cut off his penis. I said, yep. He shared my brother's Facebook post with more than 50 of his friends.
她解释说，是我祖父坚持要家里女性必须被切割。他相信如果宗教教职人员认为这有必要，我们质疑就是错的。关于是否给我切割的争吵到了失控的地步，他威胁要把我妈逐出家门。祖母对此保持沉默。在我妈告诉我真相后，我们的关系改变了。我对她的愤怒几乎立刻消失了。
And then within days, he lost his confidence. He got word from a close family member that he was on the wrong side of this and he shouldn't criticize the practice-- publicly. And "publicly" is the thing. He stopped sharing the post.
我真希望能确切地告诉你波拉人中间的事情正在改变。主要是因为秘密，人们并没真正说出他们的立场。我弟弟在联合国发言后，我父亲为他感到自豪。他为发生在我身上的事向我道歉。他说这就像有人割了他的阴茎一样。我说，是的。他把他弟弟的Facebook贴子分享给了50多位朋友。
Recently a Bohri leader in Sydney was prosecuted and sent to jail for FGM. After that, a handful of clergy from the Bohri community around the world started circulating letters saying that cutting is illegal and we should stop doing it. That's on the heels of a small group of us who have become very vocal about ending FGM. That's what I can do. That's a new Bohri tradition.
几天之内，他失去了信心。他从一位亲密的家庭成员那里获悉，他在这件事上站在了错误的一边，不应该公开批评这种习俗。而“公开”才是关键。他停止分享那个贴子了。
Mariya Karimjee. Her story came to us through a podcast called The Heart, which is really great and well-produced. You should listen to it. You can find their version of the story this week on theheartradio.org or wherever you get your podcasts. A print version of Mariya's story was originally published on the website thebigroundtable.com.
最近，悉尼的一位波拉领袖因FGM被起诉并送进监狱。在那之后，世界各地的几位波拉教职人员开始散发信函，说切割是违法的，我们应该停止这样做。这发生在一小群我们变得对结束FGM直言不讳的人之后。这是我能做的。这是一项新的波拉传统。
[MUSIC - "NEW TRADITION" BY COMPANY]
玛丽亚·卡里姆吉。她的故事是通过一个叫《心》的播客节目呈现给我们的，节目做得非常好。你应该听一听。你可以在theheartradio.org或你获取播客的任何地方找到这一周的版本。玛丽亚故事的印刷版最初发布在thebigroundtable.com网站上。
Coming up, a brother and sister with extraordinarily similar first names and completely opposite ways of dealing with what happened to their dad when they were little. That's in a minute from WBEZ Chicago when our program continues.
[音乐 - 公司合唱团的《新传统》]
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole. Every week we choose a theme and play you all kinds of stories related to that theme. This week, "Who Do We Think We Are?", stories of folks trying to reconcile their beliefs with those of someone or someones they're related to. We're up to Act Two of the show. Act Two, "Who Wants to Know?"
接下来，一对姐弟，名字极其相似，却用完全相反的方式应对小时候父亲遭遇的变故。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续，来自芝加哥WBEZ。
This last story is also about folks coming to a kind of reckoning with their parents, but in a very different way. It's about a brother and sister named Nema and Neda Semnani. Their father died violently when they were very little. Nema, the brother, actually never met his father, and their mother died of ovarian cancer back in 2010. After she died, they packed up boxes and boxes of her stuff and sent them off with various relatives.
这里是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔。每周我们选择一个主题，并为你播放与主题相关的所有故事。本周是“我们是谁？”，讲述人们试图调和自己的信仰与亲人之间差异的故事。我们现在进行到节目的第二幕。第二幕，“谁想知道？”
Nema ended up with a bunch of the boxes himself, and a filing cabinet, which he hated. He didn't want to look at any of it. Both of his parents were dead. There was history in there that he didn't want to deal with. And he was moving around a lot, apartment to apartment.
这个故事也是关于人们与父母达成某种和解，但方式非常不同。故事主角是姐弟俩：内马·塞姆纳尼和内达·塞姆纳尼。他们的父亲在他们很小的时候惨死。身为弟弟的内马甚至没见过父亲，而母亲于2010年死于卵巢癌。母亲去世后，他们装好一箱又一箱她的遗物，并让亲戚们带走。
Imagine lugging around a both literal and figurative box of just bad with you, like figuratively full of bad stuff and physically a lot of it. You know?
内马自己留下了一堆箱子和一个他讨厌的文件柜。他不想看里面的任何东西。他的父母都去世了。那里藏着他不想面对的历史。而且他搬家很频繁，公寓换了一个又一个。
Yeah.
想象一下，带着一个既是字面意义又是比喻意义的坏东西箱子到处走，在比喻意义上它装满了坏事，在物理上它确实有一大堆。你懂吗？
You're like, that's my box of bad. Where do you keep your tragedy?
是啊。
It's in this box.
你就像是，那是我的坏东西箱子。你把悲剧藏在哪儿？
It's in this box over there, in the file cabinet.
就在这个箱子里。
I remember one conversation. He was like, I'm just going to throw them away. Like angrily, I'm going to throw them out.
就在那边的那个箱子里，在那个文件柜里。
This is Neda, Nema's sister. She's three years older. She felt very differently about the boxes.
我记得有一次谈话。他当时说，我干脆把它们扔了吧。很生气地说，我要把它们扔掉。
I was like, "don't!" "Do you know what's in them?" He's like, "no." I was like, "well then, you [BLEEP]ing can't throw them away."
这是内达，内马的姐姐。她大三岁。她对这些箱子的感觉非常不同。
So Nema tucks away the boxes and the filing cabinet in a storage unit outside Washington, DC. And then a few years after their mom dies, Neda's trying to piece together the details of their parents' lives and what happened to their father. And she says to Nema, can we go check out that storage unit? So they head over there, and it's like a Hardy Boys episode.
我说，“别！”“你知道里面有什么吗？”他说，“不知道。”我说，“那你就该死的不能把它们扔掉。”
For some reason we're the only two there, but I feel like in storage units, it always feels like you're the only one there. And we opened the door of the storage unit. And there's all this crap. There's clothes and there's whatever, and there's a rusted-out filing cabinet. And I open it. And literally all by itself in this mass of stuff is just this, just this folder with my dad's name on it, sitting very patiently, as if it had been waiting for me all this time.
于是内马把箱子和文件柜塞进了华盛顿特区外的一个储藏室。母亲去世几年后，内达试图拼凑父母的生活细节以及父亲遭遇的事情。她对内马说：我们可以去看看那个储藏室吗？于是他们去了那儿，感觉就像《哈代兄弟》的一集。
It was a trove of information about their father. And it wasn't just that one folder. In another drawer there were more files, and more in some of the boxes.
因为某种原因，只有我们两个人去，但我感觉在储藏室里，总是感觉只有你一个人。我们打开了储藏室的门。全是破烂。有衣服什么的，还有一个生锈的文件柜。我打开它。在这堆东西里，有一个文件夹孤零零地立在那儿，上面写着我爸爸的名字，非常耐心地坐着，仿佛一直在等我。
And a few days later, I'm going through them, or maybe it was the next day. There are handwritten letters and Dad's passport.
那是一个关于他们父亲的信息宝库。不仅有那一个文件夹。在另一个抽屉里还有更多文件，箱子里也有更多。
She showed it to me.
几天后，我正在翻看它们，或者也许是第二天。里面有手写信件和爸爸的护照。
Can I look at his picture?
她给我看了。
Oh, yes.
我可以看看他的照片吗？
Handsome guy.
哦，是的。
Yeah, he looks a lot like Nema, if Nema shaved. And I just remember thinking. I felt like-- I don't know. It felt like I was on the right path.
帅哥。
This is what was in the box of bad, what Neda began finding out more and more about as she dug through the folders and files. So their parents were both from Iran. They met when they were students at Berkeley in California in the '60s. And they became involved in a leftist political movement there that opposed the shah of Iran. There was the revolution in '79. The shah goes into exile. And all of these leftists who had been agitating from abroad come streaming back into the country, back into Iran, high on the possibility of new freedoms in their country.
是的，如果内马刮了胡子，他长得很像内马。我只记得当时的想法。我觉得——我不知道。感觉就像我走在了正确的道路上。
Neda and Nema's parents were two of them. Except the shah was replaced by the Ayatollah Khomeini, an Islamic fundamentalist who, arguably, was even more restrictive. And when the leftists-- the secular leftists-- agitated against this new regime, a lot of them were imprisoned, including Neda and Nema's dad. Their mother was still pregnant with Nema at the time. Neda was two years old.
这就是“坏东西箱子”里的东西，也就是内达在翻看文件夹和文件时开始发现的越来越多的秘密。他们的父母都来自伊朗。他们在60年代加州伯克利做学生时相识。他们参与了一个反抗伊朗国王的左翼政治运动。1979年发生了革命。国王流亡。而这些一直在海外鼓动的左翼人士成群结队地回到伊朗，沉醉在国家出现新自由的可能性中。
She and her mother escaped back to the States. Nema was born about a month after they got there. And then, four months after that, their dad and 20 other activists were executed. And as Neda got older, this image of her father formed in her head.
内达和内马的父母就在其中。但国王被大阿亚图拉霍梅尼取代了，那是一位伊斯兰原教旨主义者，可以说比国王更为严苛。当左翼人士——世俗左翼——反对这个新政权时，他们中的许多人被监禁，包括内达和内马的爸爸。妈妈当时还怀着内马。内达才两岁。
I believed he was a superhero. He was kind of a weird superhero, though, because no one really talked about him very much. So I think maybe that's part of the reason I thought, maybe he's still in prison.
她和母亲逃回了美国。内马在他们到达一个月后出生。然后，四个月后，他们的父亲和其他20名活动家被处决。随着内达长大，父亲的形象在她脑海中形成了。
I remember asking Mom, how do you know he's dead? We left before he died, so how do you know? Couldn't he have been like a ninja?
我相信他是个超级英雄。不过他是个古怪的超级英雄，因为没人真谈论他。所以我认为这可能是我认为他还在监狱里的原因。
You said ninja.
我记得问妈妈，你是怎么知道他死了的？我们在他死前就离开了，你怎么知道？他不能像忍者一样吗？
Yeah. I don't know why ninja. Or like karate. Maybe I said karate. Couldn't he have done karate and gotten out?
你说忍者。
30 years later, every new fact that Neda uncovers about her dad is like a strand of DNA she can use to re-engineer him, to bring him back. For example, Neda learned that in Tehran, after someone informed on their father, he and Neda's mother and Neda all went into hiding. Neda only has shadowy memories of this-- more like memories of memories. She certainly didn't know back then that her family was essentially waiting for the government to come and arrest everyone. And they figured they wouldn't be waiting long.
是啊。我不知道为什么要说忍者。或者像是空手道。也许我说的是空手道。难道他不能学会空手道然后逃出来吗？
But then a week went by, two weeks went by, a month went by. And then January was February, February was March, and still nothing. And apparently the stress of it had gotten to my dad. One side of his face kind of froze and stopped working for a month or something, just like the left side of his-- or one side of his face just fell.
30年后，内达关于父亲发现的每一个新事实，都像是一条她可以用来重新构建他的DNA，让他起死回生。例如，内达得知在德黑兰，在有人举报父亲后，他和内达的母亲以及内达都躲了起来。内达对那段经历只有模糊的记忆——更像是记忆的记忆。她那时肯定不知道家人本质上是在等待政府来抓捕所有人。他们认为自己等不了多久。
Every time she found out a detail like this, she'd want to tell her brother, to share it with him. This is what Mom and Dad went through, our mom and dad. This is where we come from. But Nema, her brother, wasn't interested. Not that he wasn't interested, he aggressively did not want to know any of these details she was finding out. This whole project of exhuming the past, re-animating their parents, what did he have to gain from that?
但随后一周过去了，两周过去了，一个月过去了。一月变成了二月，二月变成了三月，依然什么都没发生。显然压力折磨着父亲。他半边脸冻住不动了，好几个月还是什么，只是一边脸瘫痪了。
She has certain fragments and puzzle pieces of the father. I don't have any of that. So I got the privilege of creating him.
每次她发现像这样的细节，她就想告诉弟弟，和他分享。这是父母经历过的事，我们的爸妈。我们来自这里。但内马，她弟弟，不感兴趣。不是说他不感兴趣，而是他积极地不想知道她发现的任何这些细节。挖掘过去、复活父母的整个项目，对他有什么好处？
It's funny that you would think of that as a privilege.
她有关于父亲的一些碎片和拼图块。我什么都没有。所以我才有幸去创造他。
I can't-- how else would you think of it? Obviously it sucks. I'm not going to say it doesn't suck. But right now my father is perfect.
你竟然认为这是特权，真有意思。
I already have 100 out of 100 right now. It can only go down. There's a very good chance that you know more than I do.
我不能——不然还能怎么想？显而易见，这很糟糕。我不打算说它不糟糕。但现在，我的父亲是完美的。
No, no, no, no. Nema, I certainly know more than you do.
我已经得了100分，满分。它只能降不能升。很有可能你知道的比我多。
OK, good.
不，不，不，不。内马，我肯定比你知道的多。
Which is a funny feeling because it's your history. I mean, it's your family.
好吧，那就好。
Yeah.
这是一种奇怪的感觉，因为这是你的历史。我是说，这是你的家庭。
Whereas Neda is swimming in the details of the revolution and the escape and the execution practically every day-- she's writing a book about it, actually-- and those details are sometimes hard to carry around. A bit of what she's learned. And here I'll just issue a personal content advisory warning to Nema, who, if you're listening to this and you still don't want to know this stuff, you should turn down the radio for a minute.
是啊。
Firstly, the group their dad was part of staged an armed uprising against Khomeini. It was a terrible plan, and it went badly. The irony is that their dad opposed the uprising, didn't take part in it. But it didn't matter. The governmental guards arrested him, bound his hands behind him with a rope, and marched him back to his parents' house.
而内达每天几乎都沉浸在革命、逃亡和处决的细节中——实际上她正在写一本书——而这些细节有时很难承载。她发现的一些东西。在这里，我给内马发一个个人内容警告：如果你正在听这个，而且仍然不想知道这些东西，你应该把收音机关掉一分钟。
This whole eerie scene ensues there, with their dad, their aunt, and these four armed guards sitting around, waiting for their mother to arrive. She doesn't arrive. She calls instead. The aunt says, everything's OK. Bring Neda to your mother's place. It was code. Her mother lived in California.
首先，父亲所属的组织策划了一场针对霍梅尼的武装起义。那是个糟糕的计划，进行得很糟。讽刺的是，父亲反对那场起义，并没有参加。但这并不重要。政府卫兵逮捕了他，用绳子把他的手反绑在身后，把他押回了他父母的房子里。
The escape through Iranian Kurdistan was harrowing and took days. They rode horses and walked and were driven by smugglers-- smugglers who abandoned them on the roadside twice. They were desperately thirsty and hungry. Neda went half crazy for a little bit from heatstroke. Again, she was two. Their mom, pregnant with Nema, fell down an embankment at one point but climbed back up and kept walking.
整个诡异的场景就在那里发生了，他和阿姨，以及四个武装警卫坐在那里，等着母亲到来。她没来，而是打来了电话。阿姨说：一切都好。带内达去你妈妈那儿。那是暗号。她母亲住在加州。
Meantime, Neda and Nema's dad was being held in solitary confinement at Evin prison. Neda describes his cell block as a prison within a prison, filled with torture devices. So Neda understands Nema not wanting to know these things.
穿越伊朗库尔德斯坦的逃亡极其艰辛，花了几天时间。他们骑马步行，由走私者带路——走私者两次把他们遗弃在路边。他们极度饥渴。内达一度因为中暑半疯了。再一次，她才两岁。母亲怀着内马，有一次跌下路基，但爬回来继续走。
That's another thing, is Neda knows about the torture. He was tortured in these things, and she knows about it. It's the difference between knowing that it happened and maybe even knowing the methods at which they were implemented. And I'm pretty sure she knows these things. Put that very high on the list of things I don't want to know. And why the hell does she want to know? Right?
同时，内达和内马的父亲被单独囚禁在埃文监狱。内达形容他的牢房是一个监狱里的监狱，装满了酷刑工具。所以内达理解内马为什么不想知道这些事。
Nema learns about these things almost by accident. Through his earmuffs, as he says, things just creep in now and then. And yeah, the torture is very high on that list of things he doesn't want to know. But practically everything's on that list.
这也是一回事，内达知道酷刑的事。他在那些东西里受到了拷打，而她知道相关细节。这就像知道事情发生了和可能知道实施的具体手段之间的区别。我肯定她知道这些东西。把那放在我不想要知道的清单的最顶端。到底为什么她想知道？对吧？
He's allowed to decide the stories he tells himself, I think. I mean, they're his parents too. I mean, I think that there's stuff that he should know, or at least be given the option to. So when someone had sent us the footage of Dad's trial, I sent it to him. And then he told me a couple days ago that he watched, like, a second of it.
内马几乎是偶然了解到这些事情的。正如他所说，戴着耳罩，东西偶尔会溜进来。是的，拷打在不想知道的清单上名列前茅。事实上，几乎所有东西都在那个清单上。
It was just long enough to see-- I watched it for 30 seconds, caring not what he said but how he said it.
我认为他有权决定告诉自己什么样的故事。我是说，他们也是他的父母。我想有些事他应该知道，或者至少有选择知道的权利。所以当有人寄给我们父亲受审的视频时，我发给了他。然后他两天前告诉我，他看了大概一秒钟。
You just wanted to--
时间足够久到看到——我看了30秒，不在乎他说什么，而是怎么说。
I wanted to see. Does he do what I do? Does he tilt his head a little bit? Does he speak with his hands? Does he gesticulate a lot?
你只是想——
And did he do any of that stuff?
我想看看。他有我那样的习惯吗？他会稍微歪着头吗？他会用手势说话吗？他有很多肢体动作吗？
Not that I could really tell.
他有做那些动作吗？
Their dad doesn't move around a lot in the video, actually. His hands are resting on a table. He looks tired, defeated. In certain moments, he seems near tears. It's not the kind of video you watch when you want to have a sunny idea of where you come from. Still, in a way, Nema had the same experience watching that little bit of the video that Neda has had this whole time in all of her research. He says it proved that his dad was a living person, that he wasn't a myth. But he doesn't think he's going to watch any more of it.
我没太看出来。
It's funny, but Neda and Nema's mom knew they'd end up each feeling the way they do about the past. She all but said it in an interview with StoryCorps, that traveling recording booth where people tell stories about their lives. In this case, their mom was just talking to one of the StoryCorps volunteers, who asked her what her late husband would have thought of the family's life in America.
其实，父亲在视频里没怎么动。他的手放在桌上。他看起来疲惫、挫败。在某些时刻，他似乎快要哭出来了。这不是你想拥有阳光背景时会看的视频。尽管如此，从某种程度上，内马在观看那一点点视频时，体验和内达在所有研究中一直经历的是一样的。他说这证明了父亲是一个活生生的人，他不是神话。但他觉得他不会再看了。
And more than anything, I think he would have been proud of his two children. He never saw his son. And his daughter, who was the apple of his eyes, they didn't see each other after she was two and a half. So his sort of ghost hovers over my daughter. But my son, who never knew him, I think has a longing for a father he never knew. But there is not a ghost hovering over him, as there is one for my daughter.
这很有意思，内达和内马的妈妈知道他们最终会以自己的方式面对过去。她在采访StoryCorps时几乎说了出来，那是人们讲述生活故事的旅行录音棚。在这种情况下，妈妈只是和一个StoryCorps志愿者聊天，志愿者问她丈夫如果看到家人们在美国的生活会怎么想。
Neda first heard that recording long after their mother died. Nema has never heard it, unless he's listening to this right now. But I did tell him what she said. And he said, that's 100% accurate. She was a smart woman.
我想最重要的是，他会为他的两个孩子感到自豪。他没见过儿子。而女儿，曾是他掌上明珠的女儿，她在两岁半之后就没见过他。所以他的鬼魂某种程度上盘旋在女儿身上。但我儿子，从未认识他，我认为他渴望一个从未谋面的父亲。但盘旋在他身上的不是鬼魂，就像女儿身上有一个。
[MUSIC - "WHAT I AM" BY EDIE BRICKELL & NEW BOHEMIANS]
内达在母亲去世很久后才听到那段录音。内马从未听过，除非他现在正在收听。但我告诉了他母亲说的话。他说，那完全准确。她是个聪明的女人。
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming and Nancy Updike. Our production staff includes Zoe Chace, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lyra Smith, and Matt Tierney. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Editorial help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Other staff, Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
[音乐 - Edie Brickell & New Bohemians的《我之为我》]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明和南希·厄普代克制作。我们的制作人员包括佐伊·蔡斯、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莱拉·史密斯和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。编辑帮助来自朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔纳·贝克。其他人员包括埃莉斯·伯格森、艾米丽·康登、金伯利·亨德森和塞斯·林德。研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖迪斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Extra special thanks to my boss, Ira Jeffrey Glass. You know, he performs magic too. And he was doing this magic trick for the Cookie Monster the other day where he presented him with three sealed envelopes.
[鸣谢]
And I was like, do you know what's in them? And he was like, no.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。特别感谢我的老板，艾拉·杰弗里·格拉斯。你知道，他也会变魔术。有一天他还在给芝麻街的饼干怪兽变戏法，当时他递给他三个密封的信封。
I'm Sean Cole. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我当时问他，你知道里面有什么吗？他说，不知道。